We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P here
is a voicemail that came in with a question
that clearly is the source of much confusion
in general in the United States.
Take a listen.
Hey David, I'm Austin.
Long time listener.
First time calling her.
I'm from Pensacola, Florida and I wanted to
get your take on the difference between a
democratic socialist and an actual socialist.
Uh, thanks for any explanation.
Uh, love the show.
Have a great day.
Okay, good.
I know that I've talked about this before,
but any opportunity to clear this up is a
good one.
This is not about my interpretation of democratic
socialist versus social Democrat.
The difference is democratic.
Socialists are socialists and social Democrats
are not social Democrats.
I know that a lot of them don't like to use
this term.
Social Democrats are capitalists who wants
a very well-regulated version of capitalism
that takes the wealth created by the capitalist
system, disproportionally for the rich and
reallocates it to social programs and government
spending to ensure that no one has a standard
of living that goes too low.
There are lots of, of comments like, well,
hold on.
A lot of democratic socialists aren't really
advocating for socializing the means of production,
but they're still democratic socialists.
Well, no, they're really not.
I mean, okay, we can redefine terms.
We can just say the terms have no meaning
anymore.
Social Democrats might be socialists and democratic.
Socialists might not.
Uh, but as defined, um, uh, in the last hundred
years, social Democrats are capitalists and
democratic socialists are not.
We can play with the definitions.
We can change the definitions, but it's really
important to understand that.
Uh, we have a great bonus.
Throw 40 you today, tons of stories from my
vacation and a bunch of other, uh, things
to discuss with you.
Um, become a member in and get instant access
to the bonus show@joinpacman.com only two
bonus shows
bluff in 2019 and then begins it properly.
He gets, uh, an election year in just a couple
of days.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].